المطالبه الوحيد لكل الناس هو تطبيق
القرار 22 54 الانتقال حل وللسلمي للسلطه
وخلينا نخلص العصابه الحكمي والناس تخلص
من غير اي فتنه بين الشعب ومن غير اي
ما يصير اي نقطه دم
[موسيقى]
يؤكد الائتلاف الوطني ان العمليه السياسيه
المتعلقه بسوريا قد تم تعطيلها بسبب عرقله
نظام الاسد لاي خطوه باتجاه
ونطالب بتنفيذ القرار الدولي 22 54 الذي
يعد تطبيقه مسؤوليه دوليه
[موسيقى]
والان وفي احاطات متكرره وخاصه الاخيره
يتم تجاهل هيئه الحكم الانتقالي نهائيا
ويتم الاستعاذه عنها احيانا بموضوع البيئه
الامنه والمحايده
[موسيقى]
فقلنا انه اننا سننفذ ما يهم الجمهوريه
العربيه السوريه في صناعه في تنفيذ مثل
هذا القرار وعلى هذا الاساس نحن سنسعى الى
الحل السياسي الذي يلزم الذي يستلزم
القضاء على الارهاب
[موسيقى]